[Music]  we are considering the possibility of  sabotage  and any other sources of the fires  starting  we will not give up until we have all  the answers  [Music]  do  [Music]  the blaze spread through the highlands  and raged suddenly  we had no chance to flee but when we  were engulfed by flames  we had to run to the city of monavgart  then we came back to find the house like  [Music]  this  [Music]  [Music]  we'll start partial payments to our  citizens who have suffered damage to  their properties  we have begun transferring a total of  2.7 million dollars  from various institutions and ministries  for emergency needs  in antalya's manav gut district  [Music]  you